the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys I feel sick today so the audio
comes out bad or memories kind of sounds
bad compared to my previous videos it's
rolled because of it so without further
ado let's just jump into it
hey guys today I'm bring you one theory
of mine which is not supported by any
League material then I'm going to talk
about Chi burns loyalty toward Cersei in
this video I'm going to consider
possibility of Clyburn working for
various the whole time I will not just
express my theory and expect from you to
believe in it I'm also bringing you the
possible proofs they're going in favor
to this theory ok let's start from the
very beginning since the first episode
Qyburn appeared on TV show they're
raising more and more unexplained
answers on a lot of questions for an
example how did Qyburn even and among
the Norton and Rivlin
prisoners set hair Hall in which Clegane
Gregor aka the mountain killed every
prisoner but somehow Qyburn survived
injury and de volcán when the castle was
taken but Robb Stark and his northern
army three seasons passed since that
happened Kaymer Hecker ization Jaime and
Cersei but still we don't know how
Clyburn ended as a prisoner at Harrenhal
you're not sure if Qyburn is working for
various since the very beginning which
actually would explain why Qyburn
volunteered to join the team which has
courted Jaime back to King's Landing
meanwhile from conversation between
Jamie and Qyburn the wolf found out that
Qyburn is an unethical former Meister
who was thrown out of the order from
conducting illegal human experiments as
we all know Qyburn her she became
extremely close considering the fact
that Cersei treated people around her
with paranoia and suspicious thoughts
especially the just ride ones while
Qyburn gains Hurstville trust we'll
bring in Gregor Clegane back to life
after he was seriously wounded by spirit
code and a Manticore venom
during the fight against Oberyn Martell
after it Cersei named Qyburn as master
of whisperers as a varus's replacement
on the small council now this is a
moment in mature bringing of some kind
of proofs as we've seen from few
episodes in season 6 Khyber has been
able to use spy capabilities or saint
little birds that wares had used in
previous seasons
now from this fact there are a lot of
specious and so far and explain things
for example in conversation between
tyrion and varys tyrion asked if he can
believe that these little birds
particularly tyrion said tell me can the
little birds get a message to the good
masters of as per the wise masters of
yunkai the benevolent and slave so
valannus on which where sends for live
of course man can be fickle but birds
always trust from this conversation we
can see that where is fully believed his
little birds and birds can be considered
as everything by the fool furthermore
verse is known as a man of knowledge and
whispers as a man that knows every step
of every limit man in seven kingdoms
also dairy came to a conclusion that
even if Khyber managed to let's call it
bribe few bears whole birds and even if
those few spires agree to betray varies
there is no way that we're gonna find it
out there is no way that none of them
wouldn't send whispered wares
furthermore verses disparagingly known
as the spider due to his vast web of
intelligent sources his sophisticated
intelligence network which is one of the
largest in the world and spends both
Westeros and Essos this fact gives me
even more doubt about where is not
knowing if the group of his spies
betrayed him little birds are worse is
found a group of spies which he educates
gives sweets and provides them
protection in return for the
informations they bring him in case you
didn't know all this means that Qyburn
is most likely working for various and
it's only preparing the ground for a new
queen you might think if Qyburn and
little birds are loyal to Varys why the
little birds inform Qyburn about
wildfire who later informs nursey about
it which led to destroy great Sept of
Baelor
along with maester Al Margaery Tyrell
Loras Tyrell high Sparrow and all little
sparrows first of all let's highlight
the fact that Farris has no oil two
House Targaryen all the time where she
has been working on a plan to bring back
to the nearest and House Targaryen the
iron throne that has been taken from
them since the first season of Game of
Thrones if you don't remember or you
don't know where she has been working
hard
virgeen's rise along with delirium apari
since the very beginning which seemed
from the first season confirms as we saw
where is Lily really discussing about
the right time to strike on Seven
Kingdoms in the tunnels under the red
keep which was overheard by our astark
verse has been advising the nurses
father as well he was one of the small
amount of man who stirred the Mad King
even when it was obvious that he is
going to lose the war in Arras his final
days when timing arrived at King's
Landing with an entire Lannister army at
his back very sworn there is no to open
the gates
whichever's refused because the grand
maester pycelle but all the Mad King
what he wanted to hear that he could
trust Lord timing which resulted with
Arras believing his former hand of the
king believing time Lancer and opened
the gates after which Lannister army
sagacity and Jaime stabbed arrows in the
back let's get back on the question
which was if Qyburn along with little
birds was actually working for Varys
why did they help Cersei to find out
about the Wildfire and later with it
destroyed the great Sept of Baelor along
with her enemies well the answer is very
simple search displaying matched
perfectly with where's plan furthermore
in our opinion very sexually order
Qyburn and his little birds to find out
if the Wildfire is really under great
Shafto bail or and if it really is to
inform Cersei about it immediately I'm
aware that most of you are confused
right now but let me explain very simple
man he was aware that if surge you
observed the most of leadership with the
Wildfire it would lead her losing her
alleys which in fact exactly happened
and this various probably expected it
gave you an opportunity to make new
alleys in his gates with Olenna Tyrell
who now only wants to rent your son her
nephew and her niece by this fact
Varys managed to provide new ally for
his queen and made a nurse's takeover
even easier by destroying great Sept of
Baelor beside the fact that various
providing a new ally for Danny they also
got rid of one Trev
they got rid of high Sparrow on his
faith militant which I'm sure would make
a lot of problems for Daenerys also the
fact
the Qyburn brought sir gregor clegane
back to life who back intercedes and
almost killed him
is something that I can get over why did
Chiron bring back to life someone who
and tapped in to kill him I have a
possible answer that question which
would be that Chiron creating the
monster created the mountain only to get
even closer to Circe which would allow
them when the time comes the raziel kill
Cersei which he thinks that he is her
most trusted protector as she thinks he
is
ever since the mountain has been brought
back to life as the mountain was her
closest and the old guard through the
sixth season he will continue to be in
the upcoming season as well as leaked
photos confirms the ones which were
taken in Dubrovnik a week ago if this
theory comes true in which Qyburn is
actually working for various and is
preparing the ground for a new queen
it would only prove once again how
brilliant my know where sexual is which
would once again confirm various high
intelligence and cunning skills but this
is only a theory which is not supported
with either leaked photos or like plot
all I know for sure is that the mountain
will follow sir she has her most trusted
protector as he did in previous season
but yeah this is only a theory which
doesn't necessarily has to come true I
read the theory which says that Qyburn
doesn't really care that much about any
of those lords and their games but
here's more about himself and the cause
of science theory says that Qyburn is
beside Cersei only because she gave in
laboratory and more resources than
anyone could ever give him so he uses it
this theory in my opinion is not
accurate this is Game of Thrones show
and every character has their role in it
Qyburn isn't that close to Cersei only
to use more resources there is something
much bigger in it I've also read a
theory about Qyburn being loyal to how
stark
supported by a fact that Robb Stark kind
of saved his life after he came at
Harrenhal
but personally I don't believe in it I'm
rather sticking with the theory which I
represented to you guys today with some
kind of proofs don't you think that
climbers whole store is a little bit
suspicious or is it just me and my work
thinking don't you think it's a little
bit weird how the mountain is the one
who slit climbers throw that hair hole
in the first place but after that Qyburn
broad amount
in fact life it would only make sense if
it's part of a bigger plan of vengeance
do you think that Bears would sacrifice
a lot of innocent lives in order to
provide the near some extra army in the
new ally in favor to make her take over
even easier and the last one do you
think that we're soul spies actually
betrayed him or Qyburn and that all the
events at the King's Landing happened
without Varys implication let me know
your opinion in the comment section down
below and please let me know which sort
of videos do you prefer is it your
videos like this one videos about season
7 news or is it maybe the series in
which I'm bringing new characters fated
season 7 supported by leaked photos and
leaked fly hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and see you in
the next one peace
[Music]